Hadi bakalım. Hazır mıyız gençler?
Kaldığımız yerden 9. sınıf RB tayfam. Ne
yapıyoruz? Üçgenlerde, açılarda yolumuza
devam ediyoruz. Önemli konulardan biri
10da 11'de 12'de karşımızda farklı
varyasyonlarıyla ilerleyen kısımlarıyla
gelecek ama bu kısmı bilmeyen o
sınıflarda gümülecek, patlayacak.
Patlamak istemiyoruz, yapmak istiyoruz.
O zaman hadi aç bakalım modül 3'ü. Modül
3te sayfa 7 8. Bir önceki dersten
ödevler. Hiç ödevleri kontrol etmediğim
aklıma geldi. Açın bakacağım dermişim.
Arkadaş onlar yapılmazsa sadece anlatıp
geçersem ben tamam hakkını veriyor
olabilirsin derse ama üstüne sen tek
başına soru çözmediğin sürece en iyi
hocayı da koysak burada ne yaparsak
yapalım mümkün değil öğrenmek için senin
de çözmen lazım. Bunu bir kere baştan
bir söyle. Kimse kimseyi kaldırmasın.
Sayfa 9. Moralleri bozmak için değil
yükseltmek için söylüyorum bunları.
Sayfa 9. Sayfa 10'u beraber işleyeceğiz.
Çok uzun bir dersi olmayacak. Temel
anlamda üçgenin açılarıyla, iç açılı ve
dış açıları ile ilgili bilmen gereken
temel şeyleri anlatacağım. sonraki
derslerde vitesi yükselteceğiz. Uzattık.
O zaman gönder gelsin hocam dedim. Bu
arada yeni çerçeveyi beğendiniz mi,
beğenmediniz mi? Mutlaka yazın
arkadaşlar yorumlara ki ben de sonraki
videolarda çerçeveyi yine o eski çerçeve
moduna geçelim mi? Gerçi ilk defa beni
bu versiyonda izleyen arkadaş için bu
çerçeve nasıl diye soralım. Tamam mı?
Etraf görünümünden bahsediyorum. Şimdi
başlık dedik ki üçgende açılar. Bunu
yani ilkokuldan beri bilmeyenimiz yoktur
aramızda. Üçgende açılardan bahsederken
özellikle iç açılardan bahsederken
toplamının kaç derece olduğunu
biliyorsun ama üçgenin tanımını
biliyorsun. Biliyor musun? Üçgen üç tane
kenar işte hocam falan. Hayır. Düzlemde
doğrusal olmayan bak bunlar doğrusal
olursa üçü birden ne olur? Üçgen
oluşturamazsın. Herhangi üç noktanın
doğrusal olmayan herhangi üç noktanın
ikişer ikişer doğrusal olabilirler.
ikişer ikişer birleştirilmesiyle
elde edilen şekle üçgen adı verilir.
Burası önemli bir mevzu. Ben ne yaptım?
Herhangi üçü doğrusal olmayan üç noktayı
ikişer ikişer birleştirdim. Üçgenimi
elde ettim. Elde ettiğim üçgenin iç
kısmında şuralarda oluşan açılara ne
dedim? İç açılar adını verdim. Bakalım
ABC üçgeninde A B C noktaları köşe.
Köşenin tanımını yapmış olduk. A B C
noktaları. AB kapalı köşeli bak parantez
doğru parçasıydı. Geçen dersten hatırla.
AC BC üçgenin kenarları A BC ACB B AC
bakurken mesela CBA ya da B AC bunlar
her biri üçgenin neleridir hocam? İç
açılarıdır. Her bir iç açısı için başına
M koyduğumuzda o açının nesi anlamına
geliyordu? Ölçüsü anlamına geliyordu.
Alfa ölçüsü. Beta ölçüsünde bir açımız
var. teta ölçüsünde alfa, beta, teta
ölçüleri var. Peki en net soruyu sorma
vakti geldi. Alfa + beta + teta daima
düzlemde çizdiğimiz bu üçgen için nedir?
180°erecedir arkadaş. Üçgenin iç açıları
toplamı bizim için ne olacaktır? 180°
olacaktır. Bunun ispatını yapalım. Belki
bugüne kadar bilmiyordun hocam. Tamam
iyi, güzel söylüyorsun. Üçgenin iç
açılar toplamı 180 de geometriyi
öğrenmek istiyorsan her seferinde o
neden sorusunu sormalısın. Şimdi derdim
şu BC kenarı var mı elimizde? Var. Bu BC
kenarına paralel olacak şekilde ve A
noktasından geçecek şekilde getirdim.
Buradan doğrumu çektim. Bu doğrunun
özelliği nedir hocam? BC doğrusuna,
doğru parçasına paralel çektik. Niye
böyle bir şey çektim biliyor musun?
Arkadaş benim derdim şu. Şurada oluşan Z
harfini sana gösterebilmek. O Z harfi
oluşmadı tabii. Şimdi daha güzel
oluşsun. Oluştu. Ters açılardan dolayı
tetı nereye taşıdım? Buraya taşıdım.
Aynı şekilde geldim. Şurada da bir Z
harfi oluşturabilir miyim? Oluşturdum.
Bu Z'den ötürü de bet'yı nereye taşıdım?
Buraya taşıdım. Biz yine geçen ders açı
çeşitlerini gördüğümüzde neyi görmüştük?
Bak doğru açı. Doğru açı kaç dereceydi?
180 dereceydi. O hal o halde alfa + beta
eşittir toplamları hepsinin ne yapıyor?
doğru açıyı oluşturuyor. E doğru açı da
180° olduğu için üçgenin iç açılar
toplamı bu sebeple 180° çık. İşin
mantığını öğrenmek işi çözmek anlamına
gelir. Şimdi hep çözdüğümüz soru
tarzları vardı. O çok kolayları bir
kenara bırakalım. Direkt harfli sorulara
bir geçiş yapalım seninle. Tamam. Hani o
ilkokuldan beri çözdüğün için o kadar
derine de inmeyelim. O kadar derine
inmek istersen sıfırdan geometri kampı
var bizim. Oradaki kitabı alıp o kampı
bitirebilirsin. Derinde mesela üçgeni
orada en temelden yani 0dan başlayıp
öğrenebilirsin. A, B, C, D, E,
Cenlerinin açılarının ölçüleri yukarıda
derece türünden verilmiştir. Buna göre
Açısı ile D açısı arasındaki fark nedir?
Ben direkt buraya odaklanacağım. Hocam
benden neyi istiyor bu soru? 2y + x -
2y'nin sonucu aranıyor değil mi?
Şuradaki açı benim için a açısıdır.
Şuradaki açı benim için d açısıdır.
Çıkardığımda geriye ne kalacak? X. Soru
benden x'i istiyor. Peki biz neleri
biliyoruz? Üçgenin iç açılar toplamını
biliyorum. Önce buradaki ABC üçgeninden
başlayacağım. Neyi biliyorum? X + Y + 4X
- Y + 2Y + X. Bütün kenarları topladım.
Neye eşitledim? 180'e. Etrafı bir
toparla. 5 tane x yaptı. Bir tane daha
ne yaptı? 6 tane x yaptı. Şuradan e bir
tane y var. Bir tane de - y var.
Birbirini götürdü. 2 tane y oldu kalan.
Cevap neye eşit? 180'e 1inci denklemi
buldum. Hemen geldim 2inci denkleme.
Elimde hangi üçgen var? DEFF üçgeni var.
Yine benzer şeyler 2 taney 4 tane x + 2y
- x toplandı. Cevap ne olmak zorunda?
180° olmak zorunda. Buradaki toplama
göre bakalım ne kaldı elimizde? 3 tane x
kaldı. + 2y 2ye buradan ne yaptı? 4 tane
y yaptı. Cevap kaça eşit olacak? 180'e.
Benim kimden kurtulmam gerekiyordu
hocam? Y'lerden kurtulmam gerekiyor.
X'ler kalsın istiyorum. O halde diyorum
ki burada her tarafı -2 ile gel çarpalım
seninle birlikte. -2 ile çarpınca ne
oldu? -12 tane x -4 tane y'i 2 ile
çarptım. -360 -2 ile çarptığımız için 3x
buradan 4y buradan toplam kaça eşitiz?
180'e. Alt alta toplamayı denedik mi
hocam? - + 4y'ler birbirini götürür.
Şurada -9 tane x kalır. 12 taneden 3
tanesini götürünce -10 burada kalır.
Eksiler birbirini götürdü. Her tarafı
-9'a böldüm. 2 kere 9 18 olduğu için
x'in cevabı ne geldi? 20° geldi. Şak
diye cevabı koyduk. Uzun uzun uğraşmadım
soruda. Benden önce istenen şey de
bilinmeyenin ne olduğunu görünce soru
kolaylaştı benim için. Zaten zor bir
soru da değil açıkçası onu söyleyeyim.
Üçgende açılarda yani ilerledikçe
sorular zorlaşacak. Şimdi burada güzel
bir taktik öğreteceğim sana. ABC üçgeni
var elimizde. 3 tane A açısı, 4 tane B
açısına, 6 tane C açısına eşit. Bunu o
kekebe gösterdim aslında arkadaş. Bak
bir şeyin 3 katını, bir şeyin 4 katını,
bir şeyin 6 katını alınca birbirine eşit
oluyor. O zaman diyorum ki öyle bir kat
seçeyim ki hepsi için ortak
gösterilebilirsin. Yani okeklerini
seçiyorum. 3'ün 4'ün 6ınnın okeki nedir?
12'dir. Bu sebeple gel seninle birlikte
buraya 12x yazalım. Neden bunu
yazıyorum? 3 tane a açısı 12x'e eşitse
bir tane açısını bulmak için 12'yi 3'e
bölersin ne kalır? 4 tane x kalır.
Anladın mı şimdi neden böyle yazdığımı?
Tam sayılarla uğraşıyoruz abi. Geldim bu
tarafa. 4 tanesi 12x'e eşitse B açısının
o zaman bir tanesi neye eşittir? 3 kere
4 12 olduğu için 3x'e eşittir. Bitmedi
derdim. Bir de aynısını C açısı için
bakalım. C açısı 6'ya böldüm 12x'i ne
kaldı? 2x kaldı. Demek ki C açısı denen
şey de 2x eşit. Şimdi getir bütün
açıları toplayalım. 4x 3x 2x toplandı.
Cevap ne çıkmalı? Üçgenin iç açılar
toplamı 180. 7 2 daha ne yaptı? 9x
yaptı. O da neye eşit? 180'e. X yine
buradan az önceki gibi 20° çıktı ama
soru ACB açısını soruyor. Bak ACB açısı
yani 2 tane x'i istiyor. Ya da biz
direkt ACB açısının ölçüsü eşittir 20 x
2'den kaç derece yazacağız buraya? 40°
yazdık. Olayı bitirdik. Gönder gelsin
dedik. Zor mu ya? Zor mu bunlar? A yine
geçen derste öğrettiğim kurallardan
birini kullanacağız burada. Aslında bu
ders o kuralı vereceğim. Hatta ispatını
da yapacağım. Bir güzellik yapacağım
sana. İspatsız olmaz çünkü. Değil mi?
Şuraya bırakayım mı kuralımızı? Neydi
kuralımız? Mehmet hocanın en sevdiği
kural diye bunu not alabilirsin. Ya da
hayatın boyunca üçgende açı sorusu
çözerken %100 söylüyorum sana. Belki de
en sık kullanacağın eee formüllerden
biri olacak. Nedir o? ABC üçgeninde
diyelim ki burası X açısı, burası Y
açısı, şurası da bizim dış açımız. Hadi
adı da C açısı olsun. Büyük C açısı
olsun. Arkadaş formül kural şu iki iç
açının toplamı geçen ders yorumlarda
istemiştim. Bunu yazan tüm arkadaşlara
teşekkürlerimi sunarım. Yazmayan
arkadaşlara teessüflerimi sunmam ama
yazarsan öğrenirsin. Hayata dair bir not
bırakırsın oraya. İki iç açının toplamı
kendine komşu olmayan dış açıya eşittir.
Cümle de önemli. İki iç açının toplamı
bir dış açıya eşittir. Yanlış. Bir dış
açı dersem burası da olabilir. Oraya
değil işte. İki iç açının toplamı
kendilerine komşu olmayan dış açıya
eşittir üçgende. Anlaştık mı? Bu kural
güzel bir kural. Neden? Sık
kullanacağım. Çünkü A BC DF üçgen.
Noktalar doğrusal paralellikler. Açı
taşıyacağız belli ki. AB DF'ye BC FC'ye
paralelmiş. FE'ye paralelmiş. Bunu niye
verirler hocam? Bunu bileniniz var mı
aranızda? Ya da sen biliyor musun bunu?
BC kesişimi doğru parçasıyla DF'nin
kesişimi G'dir. Bunu neden vermeye
çalışıyor? Bak diyor bunlar doğrusal
diyor. Geldiler bu noktada kesiştiler
diyor. Bazen o kesişimi vermenin anlamı
doğrusallığın sağlandığını göstermek
amacıyla olabiliyor. İki tane doğru
parçası burada kesişti. 57 41 verildi. X
kaç derecedir? İlk göreceğin benzer özür
dilerim benzerlik diyorum. Eşitlik
nedir? Şuradaki paralelliği düşün. Hadi
bak kırmızıyla çizeyim. Görmesi bir tık
daha kolaylaşsın senin açından. Hocam
şuradaki 57 dereceyi aldım. Bu tarafa
taşıdım. Tamam mıyız? Bitti mi işim?
Bitmedi. FE uzunluğunu aldım. Şurada BC
uzunluğunun şu parçasını aldım.
Paraleller. Yine yöndeş açılardan dolayı
41 dereceyi buraya taşır mıyım? Taşırım.
Derdim ne? Şuradaki açıya ulaşmak. Nasıl
ulaşırım hocam? İki iç açının toplamı
kendilerine komşu olmayan dış açıya
eşittir efsanesin. 57 + 41. Bana daha
kolay geliyor. Buradan farklı yolla da
çözebilirsin. 8 98° derdimiz ne hocam?
Artık burası bir doğru açı. Doğru açı
180°. Sen burayı buldun. 98°. İstersen
yazalım tepesine. E 180'den 98'i
çıkarırsam istediğim açıya ulaşmaz
mıyım? Ulaşırım. O halde orası da kaç
dereceymiş? 82 dereceymiş. Olay biter
efendim. Gönder gelsin 4. soru. Soru
çözmek de çok zevkli ya. Özellikle
geometride değil mi? Büyüteyim biraz
daha net gözüksün. ABC üçgen eşit açılar
verilmiş. 50° 115 derece verilmiş. Hocam
nereyi istiyor biliyor musun diyor
burada. Hocam diyor ki BC A açısı
şuradaki açının tamamını ben senin
yerinde olsam önce bu soruda ya hocam
benden istenen yeri ben tam
algılayamadım. Yani mesela şuna x desem
bu da x oluyor mu? Oluyor. İstediğim
yere ulaştım mı? Hayır. O zaman buraya y
diyelim mi hocam? Yiyelim. Neden bunu
yazıyorum? Önce benden ne istediğine
birlikte odaklanalım istiyorum. Hocam
benden istenen x + y kaçtır? Bunu
istiyor. O zaman x ile y ile bir şeyler
bulacağız. Aslında bir önceki derste
şalvar üçgeni vermiştim hatırlarsan.
Şalvar üçgenden birinci yol. Of bunu
yani şu an gördüm açıkçası. Birinci yol
şalvar üçgen ya da roket üçgen demiştim
hatırlarsan. Bak düzenleyerek çizeyim
onu tekrar. O roket üçgeni bir görelim.
Bir de ispatından çözeceğim çünkü. Ne
demiştik roket üçgende? Şuradaki
açıların toplamı buradaki dış açıya
eşittir ki zaten ters açılardan orası
da.
Yani x + y + 50°cenin toplamı 115°cedir.
50 dereceyi attım karşıya. X + Y'nin
cevabı ne oldu? Şurası 5, burası 6
kaldı. 65. Soru çözüldü bitti. Geçmiş
olsun. İşte geometri böyle. Yani bazen
inanılmaz hızlı çözebilirsin. Hocam ben
göremedim onu. Göremediysen şöyle
çözecektin. Şimdi şu x'i yerine yerini
yazdım. Şuraya yzdım. 115 yerinde
kalsın. Bozmayalım onu. Senden şu üçgeni
görmeni istiyorum. Kırmızı üçgeni
görebilir misin lütfen? Kırmızı üçgende
Mehmet hocanın en sevdiği kural neydi?
İki iç açının toplamı. Kendilerine komşu
olmayan dış açıya eşit x + 50. Kabul
müyüz? Güzel. Henüz burada da kalemle
yapacak bir şey yok. Şimdi şuradaki
siyah üçgeni görmeni istiyorum. Bu
üçgende de iki iç açının toplamı yani x
+ y + 50'nin toplamı kendilerine komşu
olmayan dış açı burası olduğu için 115'e
eşit değil mi? O halde ben aslında x +
y'yi buradan yine 65° bulurum. Şak diye
vururum cevabı. Orası ucundan açık
gözüküyor. Yeter o bize. 4. soruyu da
bitirmiş oluruz efendim. 9. sayfa biter
modülünde hemen sen de kitabında bunu
muhakkak tikle. Her sayfayı didik didik
ediyoruz. anlamadığımız, kafamıza zerre
yatmayan bir şeyde sayfayı geçmemeye
özen göster. Şimdi iç açı var, dış açı
da var. Şimdi dış açıdan bahsedelim
biraz sana. Genelde öğrenci şeyi çok iyi
bilir. Hocam üçgenin iç açılar toplamı
180°. Dış açılar dış bükeyi birçokgende
üçgen, dörtgen, beşgen, altıgen,
yedigen, sekizgen, engen, yengen hiç
fark etmez abi. Hepsinde dış açılar
toplamı daima bunu net duyalım senden.
360°
nedenini açıklayacağım. Önce bir tanıma
bakalım. Bir üçgenin dış açılar toplamı
neydi? 360 dereceydi. Xi, Y'yi, Z'yi
topladık. 360° çıktı. Nasıl bulunacak?
Bak şimdi sana bu ispatı iki farklı
yoldan önce bir yoldan anlatalım. Sonra
orayı bir başka bir yere bağlayayım.
Hocam öncelikle iç açılar bulunur. Ben
önce şuradan kendim bulayım istersen.
Hocam bak içeriye girmek için burası
doğru açı. 180'den x'i çıkarınca iç
açıyı bulur muyum? Mantık aynı şekilde
buradan 180'den y'yi çıkarınca bulur
muyuz? Burası da 180'den Z'yi çıkarınca
bulunur mu? Bulunur. Biz bir önceki
sayfada kimin ispatını yaptık? İç açılar
toplamının 180° olduğunun ispatını
yaptık. Madem ispatı yapıldı, biliniyor
demektir. O halde geldim yine iç açıları
kendi arasında topladım. Neye eşitlememi
beklersin? İç açılar toplamı olan 180'e.
Bak bu 180 bu 180'i yesin. Bu iki tane
180 topladım. Ne yaptı? 360 burada
kalsın. X'leri, Y'leri, Z'leri karşı
tarafa toplu halde gönderdim. Ne yaptı
bura gençlik? X + Y + Z = 360. Oha
ispata bak. Dış açılar toplamının 360°
olduğunun ispatı budur. Peki Mehmet
hocam sen bir saattir ya da en sevdiğim
kuraldır deyip deyip şu kuralı bana her
seferinde anlattın. Biz de sana
sormadık. Neden? Nedenini sordun mu sen
bana? Sormadın. İşte o neden önemli
arkadaş? Gel onun nedenini de burada
ispatlayalım beraber. Şöyle yapacağız.
Yine hani 180'de yaptığımız ispata
benzer bir ispat. Aşağıdaki BC doğrusuna
paralel olacak şekilde ben de doğrumu
çektim. Tamam mı arkadaş? Dedim ki
şuradaki Z'yi sen zaten görebiliyordun.
Bu B'yi buraya aldık. Tıpkı oradaki
ispat gibi. Ters duran C'yi de o tarafa
aldık. İzle bizi. Şuraya da C'yi de
yazdık mı? Yazdık. Dikkat et. Şuradaki
açıyla buradaki açı ters açı. Burası B
olur mu? Olur. Artık burası ne oldu? Dış
açı oldu. Bak şunun toplamı B + C benim
için nedir? Dış açıdır. Ve ben ne
biliyorum? İki iç açının toplamı
kendilerine komşu olmayan dış açıya eşit
olduğunun ispatını yapmış. Ha buraya
şunları yazmanı istiyor senden. 180 -
x'i ki o da a'ya eşit. Burada 180 - y'yi
o da b'ye eşit. Bu da 180 - c'ye bu da
eee pardon z'ye. O da neye eşit? C'ye
eşit. Anlaştık mı? Bu ispatlar neden
önemli biliyor musun hocam? İspat ispat.
Adam ispat sormuyor ki bize sınavda
diyor. Soruyu yazan kişi ispattan yola
çıkarak soruyu yazıyor. Bütün sorular
hemen hemen ispatlardan yola çıkarak
yazılır. İşte sen ispatı bilirsen belki
de bugüne kadar çözemediğin o geometriyi
çözeceksin. Sana bunun garantisini
veriyorum ben. Ben vermiyorum aslında.
Geometrinin kendisi veriyor bize bu
garantiyi. Mesela öğrendiğimiz kuralı
tekrarlayalım. ABC üçgeninde verilen açı
ölçülerine göre X kaç derecedir diye
soruyor. Daha soruya şak diye baktım.
Direkt dedim ki iki iç açı toplamda
dışarıdaki komşu olmadıkları dış açıya
eşit. Bu kadar bu soru. 3x - 5 + 30
cevap e= x + 75. 3x bir tanesi gitti ne
kaldı? 2x buranın toplamı ne? 25. Attım
karşıya ne kaldı hocam? 50. 2x 50'ye
eşitse x'in cevabı temiz işçilik 25
derecedir. Kabul müyüz? 5 biter. Gelsin
6. soru. 6. soruma baktım. Bu üçgende
verilenlere göre x kaç derecedir? Benden
onu istiyor. X neredesin hocam? Bir kere
X şurada bir yerde. Dur onu bir
işaretleyeyim. Şurada. Oraya nasıl
çıkarım? En hızlı çıkacağım yer. Hocam
bak buradan dış açıya pardon iç açıya
giderim. 180'den 120'yi çıkardık. Kaç
derece kaldı? 60°. Ardından dedim ki
Mehmet hocanın kuralı gelsin. Soru
bitsin. İki iç açının toplamı
kendilerine komşu olmayan dış açıya
eşittir. Yani 2x + 20 denen açı aslında
70 + 60'a eşit. 2x + 20'si vardı da onu
hesaplayacağım. Bekle. Şu ikisini
topladım. Kaç derece yaptı? 130° yaptı.
20 karşıya geçince burada ne kaldı?
110°. Her tarafı 2'ye bölünce x'ten
geriye ne kaldı? Sadece 55. Doğru cevap
55°. Geldi mi 7. soruya? A, BC üçgen.
Verilenlere göre X kaç derecedir? X.
Neredesin koçum? Buradasın. Nasıl
çözeceğiz ya? Yine aynısından git. Dış
açıdan da gidilebilir. Hani dış açılar
toplamı 360. Hocam belki de soruyu yazan
hocamız bunu düşünüp yazdı ama ben
oradan çözmeyeceğim. Bana daha kolay
geliyor. Yani gerçekten daha küçük
sayılarla uğraşıyorum. Buraya kaç derece
yazarsın? 180'den çıktı 40°.
Çok özür. X'i bulabilmek için ne
yaparsın? 75le 40 dereceyi toplarsın.
X'in değeri buradan ne gelecektir? 115°
gelecektir. Sorumuz çok hızlı bir
şekilde bitecektir. Ha sen dilersen
diğer kuralı da kullanabilirsin. Bu
arada kime benziyor ya? Hocam bu bizim
işte roket üçgen. Bu bizim bumerang
üçgeni. Bu bizim şalvarı üçgen. Sen adın
kazaya da diyorlar. Ha buna benziyor
gerçi değil mi? kazayana da benziyor. Y
sen nereden çözersen çöz normalde bu
soru ispattan gidildiğinde şöyle
çözülüyordu. Bir daha yapalım. İspat
önemli. İki iç açının toplamı
kendilerine komşu olmayan dış açıya eşit
95. İki iç açının toplamı kendilerine
komşu olmayan bir dış açıya eşit. x + 95
= 125. Bak bunu karşıya attığımda x'in
cevabı ne gelecektir buradan? 30°
gelecektir. Bu sorular bu kadar hızlı
çözülür. çözülmesine de ispatını
biliyorsan, kuralı biliyorsan artık çok
da uzatmazsın mevzuyu. Dersin ki, "Hocam
buradaki 3 tane iç açıyı toplayınca biz
ispatta biliyoruz, kuralda biliyoruz.
Geldik neye eşitledik? 125'e eşitledik
toplamlarını. Buranın toplamı 95 geldi.
95'i karşıya attığımda x'e kaç derece
kaldı? 30° kaldı. Bu da benim cevabım
oldu. Şakti 10 sayfada biter mi? Hadi
geçmiş olsun. Bu da bitti efendiler. E
biz yolumuzda vallahi tıngır tıngır
ilerlemeye devam ediyoruz. Ben bir
sonraki dersten itibaren bu kısmı
anlatacağım. Nerenin sonuna kadar
anlatacağım? Bir sonraki ders şurada 21.
sorunun sonuna kadar geleceğiz. Burada
artık ikizkenar üçgende, aç eee eşkenar
üçgende ya da kenarlarına göre üçgen
çeşitleri ile ilgili soru tiplerini
çözeceğiz. Ama en önemli dersi
söyleyeyim. Tamam bu bilgiler olmazsa
olmazımız ama ondan sonraki de derste
açıortay açı ilişkilerine bakacağız. Son
dönem ÖSYM'nin MEB'in en sevdiği soru
tipleri. Bak bu soru tipi var ya
bayılıyor ÖSYM bunlara. Katlama döndürme
soru tipleri derece tayfa mı olmak
istiyorsun? Burayı yutacağız uyulacağız.
Yani harbiden şu soru tarzlarını şu yeni
nesil soruları çözdüğünüzde gerçekten
ömünüz [müzik] açılacak. Sonra ben sana
yine ödevler bırakacağım. Bayağı bayağı
da ödev bırakacağım. Oo maşallah. Belki
buradan birkaçını sana çözebilirim. Ha
çors olarak da gönderebilirim.
Sonrasında direkt üçgende açık kenar
ilişkilerine geçeceğiz. Oraya kadar ne
yapıyorsun? Bu dersle ilgili şöyle bir
güzel tekrar yapıyorsun. Sonraki testi
gelmesi için bir beğen bir de yorum
tuşu. Abone olmayanlar da var. Onları da
bekleriz efendim. Rehber modalikte
kaldığımız yerden ben Deniz Mehmet
hocanız. Anlatmaya devam edeceğim.
Kendinize çok iyi bakın. Hoşça kalın.
Hoşça kalın.